Devon and Cornwall police have told us
in the past few minutes that two men
have died after being pulled from the
sea off tall Bay
Police we are informed were called to
assist the Coast Guard around nine
o'clock yesterday morning at Saturday
following reports of concern for two
people in the water off the coast of
ardikum in Tor Bay now according to
police following an emergency operation
the two men who as I mentioned were in
their 20s were pulled from the water one
was declared dead at the Sea and the
other died after being taken to hospital
their next of kin have been informed so
that just in from Devon and Cornwall
please following an incident yesterday
morning off the in the sea of tour Bay
two men in their 20s have now died